vol d'oiseau au des sus de parc
extension quartier dense avec peu
d'arbres et peu d'ombré c'est un des
secteurs habités où il fait le plus
chaud à montréal une mère d'asphalt de
béton et de goudron qui absorbent la
chaleur solaire qui est à magas yonnais
par la journée et un succès l'arrêt
large dans l'ère du ras lanuf et sa
famille encore plus plus
qu'inconfortable
on parle d'une différence entre 7 à 10
degrés de température entre le prêcheur
unis lors des chaleurs donc que
l'immense différence à la qualité déjà
elle est aussi flagrante selon qu'on
soit riche ou pauvre l'exemple du
boulevard l'acadie et parlant il sépare
deux mondes à l'est le gris de parc
extension
un des quartiers défavorisés de montréal
à l'ouest la verdoyante ville de mont
royal qui a une population beaucoup plus
nantis est parc extension et en orge
saga met en oeuvre historiquement les
quartiers plus défavorisés au moins
dames ont plus de béton ya connu un
effort un peu moins de prendre les
espaces de vie agréable
montréal doit donc verdir les
arrondissements qui en ont le plus
besoin un exemple souvent cité a été
réalisé il y a dix ans c'est ce petit
parc de la voisine riz dans montréal
nord entourée d'immeubles de logements à
prix modique il a remplacé une section
d'un grand stationnement au grand
bonheur de plusieurs résidants
6 3
c'est une impression a connu des joies
zola el djoudi feuilles qui plane
d'alevins plus l'impression d'avoir la
même heure à petit dans la grèce nous
coûte rien que vous le remarquez qu
bouge énormément non même un besoin puis
on est entouré de végétation comme le
gssa se pose il ya une limite à ce que
le corps peut tolérer comme chaleur et
on sait que les autres challenges mais
ça vient avec un stress important sur le
corps un stress cardiovasculaires donc
quelqu'un qui vit dans une chaleur
acheter des maisons neuves ou à montréal
nord deux fois plus de risques de
décéder à la des conséquences de la
chaleur qu une personne qui vit à
autrement huawei ce manque
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les
initiatives de verdissement se
multiplient comme jamais ce 22 juin on
enlevait une partie d'asphalté dans
cette ruelle voisine de l'autoroute 40
pour en faire une ruelle verte
l'organisme ville en vert qui est
derrière le projet intervient dans trois
arrondissements du nord de la ville donc
sur 2021 on a eu on a participé à des
projets n'a planté 140 arbres et 316
autres végétaux donc ses autres végétaux
savait tous qu'il plante grimpante des
arbustes et puis des vivaces clémentine
moss talent nous avait donné rendez vous
au parc jarry le stade figé à les courts
de tennis voisins et les stationnements
forme l'îlot de chaleur au milieu du
parc on voit que c'est un grand espace
ouvert avec très peu d'arbres donc nous
on a planté des arbres pour apporter de
l'ombre âge et puis pour apporter plus
de fraîcheur
18 nouveaux arbres et quelques plantes
grimpantes le long des tennis ont donc
été plantés on sait que un homme peut
fournir de l'oxygène pour quatre
personnes donc je dirais que tout geste
contre des arbres diversifié faut miser
beaucoup sur la biodiversité pour éviter
une crise comme celle de l'agrile du
frêne
l'épidémie de l'agrile du frêne combiné
à l'urbanisation ont d'ailleurs faire
reculer montréal une récente étude de
statistique canada a conclu en utilisant
des images satellites que la ville
comptait plus des espaces verts en 2001
qu'en 2019 on a planté beaucoup d'âme et
on a dû en abattre plusieurs dizaines de
milliers à cause de l'agrile du frêne
l'agrile du frêne c'est un problème qui
est moins agressif en ce moment mais qui
continue d'être présent au cours de la
dernière année montréal a encore dû
abattre dix mille freine le même impact
énorme parce que il faut partir de là
basque la voiture est une app qui est
beaucoup plus efficace en termes de lieu
contre les îlots de chaleur cas qu'il ya
une place rue on l'apprend en mode
rattrapage la ville dans son nouveau
plan climat s'est donc engagé à planter
500 mille nouveaux arbres d'ici 2030
soit 50000 par année et on vient de
publier le bilan de la première année du
plan climat 20-28 où on sait que on a
planté un peu plus de 40 milliards donc
on est un peu moins 10% de notre cible
mais on est sur la bonne voie si je me
fie au nombre des projets qui a ici qui
à quel point est ce qui se fait à
montréal et inspirant dans d'autres
villes on peut considérer qu'on est
vraiment sur la bonne voie mais le gros
du travail reste encore à faire pour
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur et il
sera important d'un rapport de
ressources naturelles canada estime que
montréal pendant 2070 devrait connaître
27 jours de 32 grille plus dans l'année
c'est trois fois plus aujourd'hui